stock market taking a hit as big tech
and oil companies warn kovid 19 is
taking a toll on their businesses
but national economic council director
larry kudlow has hoped for next year
we're going to take another bad hit in
the second quarter because of the
national shutdown
because of the virus the other hand the
congressional budget office and private
forecasters
seem to agree with president trump that
the second half economy
is going to show very significant growth
going into 2021
so what can we expect as more states
reopen throughout this transition month
joining us now to discuss white house
economic adviser kevin hassett
kevin thanks for being with us this
morning really appreciate it give us
give us the white house perspective on
the month of may what is your hope
when the month is out where do you hope
will be
well i think what we're seeing is that
probably by the end of
may almost every state will be mostly
open economically right now
there's a heck of a lot of gradual
opening going on even
some states are starting with safe
distancing and so on
to follow our guidelines and open even
restaurants safely
and so i expect that what's going to
happen is that we're going to gain more
and more experience
about how to run our economy safely at
the same time
you know our access to testing is going
to go way up
and you know our access to medical
supplies so that we don't have to worry
about hitting capacity should people get
sick we'll go up
and we're going to monitor the situation
closely but but make no mistake about it
that it's really really good news
that we've been able to open up as soon
as we have and to do so according to the
guidelines that doctors burks and fauci
have set out because that means that the
sort of harm from stopping the economy
is reduced significantly by getting it
going sooner well it's great news i mean
everyone wants to be back out and open
again
what indicators are you going to be
looking at the most closely
either health or economic as you gauge
how powerful the return is
you know every everybody in the white
house gets daily updates on what's going
on with the disease
in every state we even have it at the
county level and we're also getting data
every week on claims for unemployment
insurance
and you know next friday we'll get a
jobs report which will be the first
glimpse of sort of how bad the shutdown
has hurt things and so
we're watching everything we can get our
hands on we also have access
to credit card data so that we can get
like a real-time glimpse
at what's going on in the places that
are open as opposed close
as opposed to the places that are closed
but you know make no mistake about it
what's going to happen is that we're
going to minimize the harm by opening
now as much as we can
but you're going to see some economic
data over the next few months that's as
bad as you've ever seen
you know we turned the economy
completely off which is something that
just hasn't ever happened before
and so you are going to see a very very
big increase in the unemployment rate
a very big decline as larry kudlow
mentioned in second quarter gdp
but most forecasters expect the second
half can rebound from that
and the sooner we get going the more
likely it is that that'll be true
you know kevin you mentioned credit card
debt a lot of people are sitting on that
or businesses have been helped by the
ppp
they're they're funding their payrolls
but they're waiting and to see what
happens next there's
already talk possibly on capitol hill of
a fourth stimulus bill democrats
pointing towards states republicans
saying hey let's not bail out the fiscal
irresponsibility of states through a
coronavirus bill
if more comes from washington what
should it look like
right well the president has said that
he categorically rejects the idea of a
bailout for states that have been
irresponsible for a long time
but to the extent that the costs of
covid
uh on states you know blue and red uh
you know all of them are high enough
that maybe they need financial support
then he's willing to negotiate about
that should there be a phase four deal
i think right now because there's been
good news really that the opening up is
starting to happen
you know faster than we expected it
appears to be doing so safely
then there is a chance that we won't
really need a phase for it so i think
that what the president has told us
is to you know update him every day on
the status of everything and to be kind
of in a wait and see mode
and at the same time what we're doing is
we're developing plans
uh for whatever eventuality occurs and
so if it gets worse
we've got a plan for that as well we got
to leave it right there kevin hassett
thank you so much for your time we
really appreciate it
thank you